thank you to brilliant for supporting
pbs
hey hun yeah
what would you do with a billion dollars
i think i'd spend one-third on fighting
poverty one-third towards medical
research and one-third
[Music]
t-minus five
four
yeah what you said
[Music]
what does it mean to be a billionaire
it's not someone who makes a billion a
year or has a billion in cash stored
away somewhere like some people believe
instead a billionaire is someone whose
net worth is at or above 1 billion
dollars meaning after subtracting their
debts and liabilities their assets add
up to a billion or more assets can
include cash real estate stocks and
pretty much anything that is valuable
enough to trade in for money as of 2021
there are 2
755 billionaires in the world which is
660 more than last year their net worth
can fluctuate but as of early november
elon musk was in the top spot with a
staggering 307 billion he recently
eclipsed the current runner-up amazon
founder jeff bezos over the last year
these men have made money so fast that
if they saw one thousand dollars lying
on the ground it literally would not be
worth their time to bend down and pick
it up billionaires have more money than
anyone could reasonably spend in a
lifetime leading many to wonder is it
evil to be that rich
this is a complicated question that
could cover several episodes and because
it's about ethics it's fairly subjective
but we'll look at some of the main
arguments in this debate give our
thoughts and then let you decide first
let's look at the wealth gap between the
richest and poorest people in america
economic inequality
more than doubled between 1989 and 2016.
jeff bezos bill gates and warren buffett
collectively own more wealth than the
bottom half of all american households
that's more wealth held by three people
than by over 160 million during the
first year of the coven 19 pandemic
billionaires grew 54
richer while the number of people in
poverty around the world increased by
over a hundred million some defenders of
billionaires argue that they deserve
their wealth because of all they add to
society like job creation for instance
amazon currently has about 1.3 million
employees around the globe
but are those jobs really new or just
shifted from the thousands of small
retailers that have gone out of business
during amazon's rise to dominance while
there's no way to assign an exact amount
of blame for other companies demise
there's no doubt that giant retailers
like amazon and walmart steer customers
away from smaller companies and whether
you're a billionaire business owner or a
billionaire hedge fund manager the
easiest way to make money is to ensure
that you are hiring as few people as
possible at wages that are as low as
possible according to the small business
administration firms with less than 500
employees are responsible for creating
almost half of new jobs so even though
giant companies undoubtedly add jobs to
the economy they are by no means the
only ones okay so what about innovation
and convenience it's hard to deny that
amazon has made shopping a lot quicker
and easier and if their 386 billion
dollars in sales last year is any
indication the service amazon provides
is quite popular jeff bezos certainly
deserves some credit for that but does
he deserve all of it
after all it's not like he came up with
the idea people have been predicting the
advent of online shopping for decades
the technology that finally made it
possible the internet was originally
developed with taxpayer dollars and the
physical infrastructure it depends on
roads bridges electrical grids also paid
for by taxes aka you and me it's safe to
say that if jeff had never been born
we'd all still be buying our books
batteries and bug spray online we're not
saying he doesn't deserve to be rich he
built a company that a lot of people use
and like which no one would do without a
financial incentive but when you take
into account just how many people helped
earn those billions
it seems a bit lopsided that's why some
politicians are pushing for a 70
income tax on the ultra wealthy to help
close the inequality gap now that number
might sound high but it's actually much
closer to what it was between 1932 and
1981. during that time the top tax rate
never fell below 63 percent and rose as
high as 94
some are also pushing for an additional
wealth tax of up to six percent on
billionaires which would tax all assets
in their net worth sounds great in
theory but there's no guarantee it would
work since billionaires are notorious
for dodging taxes
the lawyers consultants and accountants
that make up the so-called wealth
defense industry can find tax breaks and
loopholes hide money offshore and employ
other tricks that are technically legal
but no doubt sketchy bringing
billionaires to an income tax bill of
well
relatively zero
one of the sneakier ways billionaires
avoid taxes is by taking out loans yes
you heard that correctly the ultra
wealthy borrow money
lots of it not because they need to like
regular people but because it allows
them to access their wealth without
technically producing income here's how
it works if a billionaire takes out a
huge salary they'll pay a 37 income tax
on a bulk of it which is why so many of
them pay themselves low salaries for
instance jeff bezos's base salary at
amazon in 2020
eight was 81
forty dollars his real wealth is in the
value of all the amazon stock he owns
which increases every year but if he
ever sells any of that to say buy a boat
or a new house he'd have to pay 20 in
capital gains tax instead what he and
many other billionaires do is take out
low interest loans to finance their
luxurious lifestyles loans are not
considered income by the irs and they
can even write off the interest as a
deduction when that loan comes due
they'll take out another one to pay the
first one they can keep this going
basically until they die since who would
ever deny a loan to a billionaire but
let's assume for the sake of argument
that there is a billionaire out there
who is paying their taxes and not
exploiting anyone are they evil just for
having that much money when there's so
much poverty disease and calamity in the
world
well not if they're helping to do
something about it and we can't deny
there are some very charitable
billionaires warren buffett has given 42
billion dollars in his lifetime bill and
melinda gates have given 30 billion some
billionaires have even given so much
that they're not billionaires anymore
but the fact of the matter is for every
charitable billionaire there are far
more hoarding their money
only 223 billionaires less than 10 of
them have signed the giving pledge a
promise to give away a majority of their
wealth to charity or philanthropy during
their lifetime or in their wills and
jeff bezos is not one of them though his
ex-wife mackenzie scott did sign the
pledge and has given away over 5 billion
since their divorce leaving her with a
paltry 55 billion
sad but even if every billionaire gave
away half their money to charity we're
still letting a handful of unelected
people decide which causes are
worthwhile and which aren't ideally a
representative democracy like ours would
use taxes and elections to give the
people at least some say in how our
excess wealth should be allocated don't
get us wrong the issue is not black and
white it's not like there's some
specific dollar amount where a plucky
entrepreneur suddenly becomes a scheming
super villain
capitalism isn't perfect but it's a
system that allows people to reap the
benefits of their risks and hard work
and has lifted millions out of poverty
in the last hundred years that's why
some economists say that holding
billionaires accountable is actually a
defense of capitalism the scale of
inequality in america today is virtually
unprecedented when so many families are
struggling to make ends meet when so
many schools and public programs are
starved for cash meanwhile half the
nation's wealth is being hoarded by a
handful of people
well that's when citizens start to feel
like their economic system has failed
them and they either want to fix it
or look for another one
and that's our two cents
hey before you go pbs digital studios
and two cents wants to hear from you we
do a survey every year that helps us
make more of the stuff you want to see
you even get to vote on potential new
shows take the survey at the link in the
description and let them know two cents
is your favorite thank you to brilliant
for supporting pbs
brilliant is an online learning platform
for stem with hands-on interactive
lessons you'll get to see math science
and computer science in a new way
through visual examples
brilliant is for curious learners both
young and old professional and
inexperienced for example for those who
want to strengthen their knowledge of
probability and statistics to better
understand finance brilliance
probability statistics and finance
learning path is a good fit for you
it provides you with the fundamentals of
probability and statistics to help
quantify predictions or you can jump
ahead into statistical modeling matrices
and markov chains that are used in
quantitative finance
brilliant will guide you through as you
learn by doing the powerful mathematics
and statistics used to model the chaos
of the financial markets to learn more
about brilliant go to brilliant.org
two cents
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
patron
for more about how wealth affects your
psychology check out our video does
wealth make you meaner
you